[Music]
Natalie Portman's comment people are
talking about it how she made that
all-male nominees director calm and how
did you feel about that and here are the
all-male nominees well you know that you
know it's we have a there's also a
watershed happening right now slowly
maybe not fast enough for women
directors I mean you know you have we
have penny Jenkins you know we have some
amazing women's that have come forward
you know mud bound and and and Lady Bird
this is a pretty incredible year and I
think you'll be seeing some nominations
I'm predicting at the Oscars this year
for a woman director if not if not
several what can you say it made me
laugh it made me smile look it's been a
little glaring that women directors
don't get nominated so often and it is
odd particularly when their films were
being celebrated in every other way so I
thought it was interesting to highlight
it and what a difficult category to
present without saying something about
race so she did it so perfectly how did
you react um I believe I looked at Greta
I'm not sure I think first my jaw
dropped a little bit because you know it
was a it was a nice ballsy move I loved
it
you